the Joe Rogan experience yeah well we
planned episode 666 that was also his
idea those the last time he wore a pope
outfit and I wore my white NASA outfit I
have a white NASA outfit and an orange
one that was awesome
but yeah 13 13 is a real thing but we
aren't really on 13 13 because just like
podcasts on planes and they're out 70mm
a shows my companion's yeah yeah that's
a crazy number what you guys are talking
about anyone interrupt a conversation
but this has sort of just come out to
help with the deep fake stuff adobe's
announced that they've got a tool that
they've the I don't know how well it
works right now they just show a picture
so they don't show it an action or
anything but it's a way to de tell if a
photo has been manipulated with
Photoshop oh I'm wearing keep that off
those Instagram hoes nobody knows that
anybody looks like you know I mean do
those this some Instagram people
literally look like cartoons like you
look at their photos you're like what
are you what you're not that's not a
picture yeah I've never [ __ ] with the
a path face-to-face toon I think as a
lot of people use so a really you can
just draw some guys where you do it yeah
for sure they do their whole face is
blurry it's like what's happening you
know I put my glasses on closer out I'm
like what are you you're spray paint
weirdly rosy cheeks yeah your spray
person well spray what we're talking
about Instagram filters like AI Dobies
new AI tool can spot when a face has
been Photoshop yeah so saying that keep
that off to Instagram hose yeah you got
like no you got one Instagram person who
is actually a CGI she's like oh I've
heard of that yeah people didn't know
her name yeah well they're saying
they're gonna do that the models now you
know they do that with houses like
sometimes you look at a picture and
you're like what it's wait a minute is
this real and like under construction
currently will be completed summer of
2020 like whoa so this is not a picture
of a house he's a CGI house yeah it's
got a shadows and the floor has texture
I mean it looks [ __ ] real man yeah
I've seen some real ass looking houses
and that's you know real estate agents
using that [ __ ]
I wouldn't like a clothing designer have
like the perfect body to complement
their perfect clothes you know yeah that
uh I'm sure you've shown this on your
billion times but yeah that you're
talking about the AI that just generates
people yeah that shakes fake models
beautiful perfect people yeah every way
mm-hmm yeah and every way I agree
every way perfect in fact it's it's
funny that some people trip out about
people that look really good on
Instagram and they say they're they're
giving off unrealistic body images hmm
and that this is something we should
stay away from unreal it's like that guy
from Vox was doing that about
he got everybody's hating on him because
he was saying that about gaither straps
that they they put out unrealistic body
images and that you should think about
them the same way you think about
cigarette ads or or liquor ads yeah
exactly
what no they're in shape unrealistic is
such a crazy thing to say when you're
actually looking at a real person yeah
unrealistic body expectations um no that
guy goes to gym and that's what you look
like when you go to the gym that is real
that's really not just realistic that's
real it's not unrealistic some people
don't want to look at other people that
look good I read this article by a
therapist who is saying like that was
the other one
Julie you posted that dad bods are more
attractive to women than rock-hard abs
survey said the death survey said was in
front of their [ __ ] fat husbands 100%
had used millionaires you know did they
well it's the Chris Pratt and Leonardo
DiCaprio as well Chris Pratt is not have
a dad bod he's sticking his stomach guys
been silly huh that guy's jacked
I mean I meet him in real life he's he's
a stud who's the other guy you know
Caprio yeah bro yeah do you think that
dad bod you know like you hear this like
usually find out this way down the line
but like some phenomena in society was
like cooked up in a boardroom right like
for example let's say I don't know you
made Twinkies and you realize like [ __ ]
man people like really getting into this
ketogenic diet and working out and there
could be a potential you probably have
some a eyes
like hey we've got like a health craze
predicted for 2021 meaning Twinkie sales
are gonna drop by like 50% cuz guys
don't want to they don't want to be fat
right and so then you start
disseminating into the world like
alright let's come up with this thing
what so what's a way to call somebody
out of shape but like to connect it to
their virility because they're a dad bod
yeah dad bot so then you start getting
it out there like you know it helps if
any product that is like bad for you
kind of depends on two things one that
it tastes [ __ ] good and two that you
can trick yourself into believing it's
worth eating right like it needs those
two things like in other words if there
was like delicious uranium like some
lunatic created like the sweetest most
flavorful uranium biscuit eat that [ __ ]
you know you're gonna go Chernobyl
[ __ ] oh your stomach's gonna melt at
the dinner table but if you could come
up with like you know a nice IPA like
you were saying or some kind of thing
that's oh it's just poison basically
it's gonna destroy your liver over time
it'll be a slow progression and you
could like sinking alcoholism you know
your personality will change and it like
nobody would do that yeah don't even
know what you're saying right now they
go no one's gonna do that such a stupid
premise no one's gonna drink poison
slowly toxified your liver shut who
would even do that [ __ ] man I would
never do that I mean I drink if I'm
sophisticated
[Applause]